all right
you remember peaches yeah peaches man
that was man that was one of my first
little hearts man
she was one of the girls one of the
first girls to let me know that there
was some real ones out there that accept
you when you're up
cause she got with me man i was way up
running around with a louis vuitton bag
with 13
000 in it jury on like 90 going north
from jerusalem
and she just wanted to get with me you
know what i'm saying and she was with me
man
i'm talking about like like for like
four
stores you know what i'm saying she was
with me man you know what i'm saying i'm
talking about doing it and you know
with the thing in the hand and
everything with me you know what i'm
saying
she was with me man laying them down
leave them kind of like a gazelle man i
promise you man
and uh her man yeah and then uh
i'm telling you man she was like i mean
me and pizza was like
it was up there when was going up blue
oh man they start smoking dough i was
selling dope smoking though man
and then they start going down and i'm
telling you man
she was with me man i went to jail
she came to see it she came to see me
sent me money she was doing bad too man
cause you know
she was kind of doing she was kind of
bad without me you know what i'm saying
because i was
you know uh but she got better man
because
she started doing some of the things
that i told her man
she got so good man she started thinking
she was a boy
she started thinking she was a boy
wearing boxers and trailers and stuff
and
and she got a girl too too you know what
i'm saying
she got a girl in two too you know but
uh we stay cool though
we stay cool through it all man we stay
cool through it all man
and she's something else man i wish i
could find the now she's from honor man
she's from honor man
she come from the 30s man they called
her too sweet
yeah some of them older older [ __ ]
older than me you know what i'm saying
she was running with them you know what
i'm saying
and then i come with my old ass
and she got with me and uh
and we did the damn thing we did the
damn thing for a while we got to dig up
peaches
oh yeah peter's family i got a father
man her name is gwendolyn ray man her
name is gwendolyn ray man
gwendolyn ray this is where i stay right
now downtown baby you know what i'm
saying if you've ever seen this you
better come holly at your boy man
cause uh i'll miss you like ninety going
north girl i mean
you guys started with gangs at what age
huh you got started with gangs i started
the games at like 11 years old man i ran
with tookie that's why my name is little
man
turkey is one of the tookie and raymond
washed it
was something once they called me little
man they wouldn't they wouldn't even let
me
join them you know what i'm saying they
started a a west side they started
uh uh uh took in a rainy monster come
from eastside originally but this was
the beginning of the hoover game
the beginning of this beginning of west
side
see the beginning of west side is is the
difference of the beginning of hoover
the beginning of hoover
uh i was i was a west side first west
side underground
that they started underground because
there's a lot of us it was a lot of us
justice
uh wanting to be down with the west side
and uh they started
us baby they had baby [ __ ] but we was
kind of like that's all
offshoots of the crypt oh yeah this
offshore they had baby crips but we was
younger than the baby crips you know
what i'm saying
and uh we started underground we started
underground [ __ ] and uh which was still
part of the west side you know what i'm
saying but uh
and and we had some older we had some
older homies too we had some big homies
from underground too you know what i'm
saying
and uh uh uh uh we had some big homies
from underground too
and because they they taught us you know
what i'm saying they taught us the way
you know they taught us the way and
that's where i stay you know i'm saying
west side
not give enough ease up for so
myself but uh steel and that was that
was before the drive-by era
the drive-by here the drive-by air i was
never really with that drive-by era you
know what i'm saying
uh yeah no i was in the drive-by air but
i was never with it you know what i'm
saying drive-bys was just something that
i couldn't do because i you got to know
who you're getting at and you know what
i'm saying
if you want to put it to somebody you
put it to them you know what i'm saying
you don't try to hit no pack cuz
you know what i'm saying they got a they
have a red rag and stuff you know i'm
saying the one time i did do that
i i didn't like it you know what i'm
saying i didn't like it you know what
i'm saying and i got sick and everything
you know it just
it just wasn't right because i didn't
know who i was getting at you know what
i'm saying
that color [ __ ] i i wasn't you know you
know
it's just a bunch of them and a butt's
bust and i had one
and uh they had some and you know we did
the damn thing
you know in inglewood you know what i'm
saying which was really they side the
red side you know
we did the damn thing but uh i really i
really wasn't one for the drive-bys and
stuff just
popping at people because you know i'm
saying like there they go and i don't
know who they are you know what i'm
saying
you know they got to color us to know i
want to know you know what i'm saying i
want to say
you know who who i got you know what i'm
saying and i got
so i can't say it you're talking about a
prison guy
huh you know a lot of people over 20
years man over 20 years i've done a gang
in prison time man and i started off
yeah i started off a
central juvenile hall lost to pedrinos
you know what i'm saying i started off
that way
and uh and kept going i was in
placements and stuff you know what i'm
saying my parents
my grandma raised me and she didn't know
what to do it
do what to do with me at age 12 you know
what i'm saying today's twelve i'm
running the streets at three o'clock in
the morning
with with with with people like monk uh
buddha
you know what i'm saying rest in peace
monk rest in peace uh you know what i'm
saying
uh uh west side original starters of
west side [ __ ]
you know the original start of the west
side [ __ ] i ran with them at age 11 and
12. you know what i'm saying
i ran with them and that's what we
branched off you know
we west side but we was underground and
and then we uh you know we ran with the
baby crips but we was underground but
and then we turned hoover and
neighborhood which is why
i which is why i never was with the funk
with the hooves in neighborhoods i never
was with that really
because you know i i ran with them
in another gang you see what i'm saying
but we split up
i went hoover and they went
111 i ain't gonna say dummy living i
ain't gonna diss them they would they
went 111 and
and uh you know stuff like the
neighborhood and stuff like that you
know what i'm saying
you know i got a little a lot of love in
his you know
with uh some in his the i got beginning
of
of love it's just a a street that will
separate one gang from
and it will and it will be six cause i'm
from 107. you know what i'm saying i'm
from 107 hoover
and uh you know what i said we got 11
dudes cooper nine deuce nine four
five you happen to be born a couple
blocks over you'd be in a different gang
right you being a you being another gang
or you could be from that gang
living way to hell in timbuktu also you
know what i'm saying because we got
chapters in
oklahoma arizona you know what i'm
saying
you know that people that's
from the land we call we call la the
land you know what i'm saying
and when you're from the land you know
what i'm saying like me i'm from the
land i'm
born and raised you know general
hospital right over right around the
corner you know i'm saying
born and raised you know what i'm saying
uh i'm from the land but i've been to
utah
but we all all of us refer to l.a and
california
as the land you know what i'm saying
because it's where it all started at you
know what i'm saying
and uh and like i said we branched off
and and informed
our hood in other states you know i'm
saying
some say even other countries i haven't
seen none from other countries yet
but i i know we there though i know
we're there like a mug who
those games would be called crips or
hoovers there would be hoovers hoovers
and they would be hoover criminals now
you know what i'm saying
uh we started off hoover crips you know
what i'm saying
but we had so many enemies you know what
i'm saying what used to be saying what's
the crypt for you know what i'm saying
we don't get along with 98 of them you
know what i'm saying so
we said hoover criminal you know what
i'm saying so we got along with who we
want to you know now
now we get it on who want to get it on
with us you know what i'm saying you can
get along with us or you can get it on
with us
we don't care you know one way or
another you heard me
one way or another you know what's that
and back then the gangs were making
money how you're you're
robbing things you're yeah back then i
was a jewelry stole rob
the crack was big then right and crack
crack crack came you know what i'm
saying crack came you know what i'm
saying when crack came
cocaine was their first potter has
always been here you know i'm saying the
potter cocaine was always here you know
and i was in it even back then at a
young age you know what i'm saying
twelve hundred fourteen hundred dollars
for a house uh three hundred and fifty
dollars for an eight ball
now you get a ball for a hundred dollars
or eighty dollars eighty dollars if you
know somebody
you know what i'm saying but it's 152
people that
can't get the right connections now you
know what i'm saying it's 150 a ball now
you know what i'm saying
which is crazy and uh i really can't
make no money in it no more because
spending 150 for three and a half grams
you have to sell pretty much
micro dots and don't nobody won't know
micro dot they're trying to get high you
know
they want the big things you know i'm
saying i can't afford to give them the
big days because i don't have
the big things you know what i'm saying
chickens i ain't got no chickens
other than that uh-huh that that
fascinating uh
jewelry store story you told last time
oh wait what's the craziest thing you've
seen in your in your gang life
in my gang like the craziest thing i see
man well i've seen it all you know i'm
saying i've seen it all from a from a to
z
in the game like you know what i'm
saying because it goes down you know
what i'm saying people getting sharmed
up
people get served up and doing some some
things you won't believe you know i'm
saying running down a street butt [ __ ]
uh locking on the locking on the
telephone poles and you can't pull them
off and stuff
you know it was good oh oh i've seen
i've seen it all you're saying i've even
seen people
uh lose their life behind uh you know
what i'm saying another person
under the influence under the influence
under influence you know
it's in books now you you can't even say
i know i know
i could have wrote a book or two about
it
you can do or say just about anything
under the influence you know what i'm
saying that's why their credibility is
no good in court
if you could ever prove if you could
ever prove like i've done
that somebody smoked an extra large
amount of cocaine and stuff you know i'm
saying and then try to say that you
robbed them
and stuff like that when they've
actually given you the stuff when it was
under the influence and stuff like that
and then wind up telling the police on
you later that you robbed them and you
have the stuff because
and they call it evidence you know and
i'll be like wait a minute though this
person sold me this or gave me this you
know what i'm saying and and you know i
said oh i gave them something for this
you know what i'm saying and i tell them
quick
hey i gave him some drugs for it you
know i'm saying yeah i give him some
money for it you know i'm saying
whatever the hell i gave him
i would tell the police quick when they
tried to take me to jail for for robbery
or something
that you know what i'm saying i just
bought from this fool you know what i'm
saying
it goes down like that though and the
gay life exists in prison as well right
the gang scene oh the gangster in prison
oh the gangster in prison something else
right now it's really a brown against
black you know what i'm saying
and white you know what i'm saying uh uh
right now
that's how it is and and how it got that
way against
a black and brown
i know but i don't know i'm just going
to say that the the shot callers
of the brown had problems with the the
shot callers of the black
and boom there it is and this [ __ ] hit
the street bam
we're no longer able to be with them or
kick it with them the way we used to you
know what i'm saying because we have
mexican homies you know what i'm saying
that was so down and mexicans you know
blacks and mexicans
uh gangs were so down that you know it's
unbelievable you know what i'm saying
it's unbelievable you know and it still
is today but
it's just not as much as it used to be
because our races have
races define uh uh most gang lines now
which mexican gangs or black gangs are
more uh more powerful
in the pen in the pen it's like running
neck and neck
you know what i'm saying but on the
street the mexican concern
on the street the mexicans got it
because they got to connect
they from mexico you know what i'm
saying they got that border you know
what i'm saying
they take it to another level yeah take
it to another level they can't take it
to another level we can get with them on
that level too you know what i'm saying
because
we've been buying kilos from them
forever you know what i'm saying
and the right black people have so much
money now that
it is it's uncontrollable you know what
i'm saying it's a pretumable
you know what i'm saying also you know
what i'm saying you just can't
understand it you know
and uh aks oozies grenades you know what
i'm saying
i've had them all sticks of dynamite you
know i've had
i've had everything you know what i'm
saying i take nails
to sticks of dynamite you know what i'm
saying and stuff like that you know what
i'm saying i heard the stories about
and threw them in places the fbi or the
government or whatever putting uh boxes
of guns and
and crack cocaine in the streets hey man
it's so true it's so true but it's it's
not really
it's not really from the the real real
good
side you know what i'm saying it's from
the bad side of the good side because
it's bad size and good size
to every side is what it is you know
what i'm saying that's what it is it's
not it's not the people that's way up
that's doing it in the police it's the
people that's down
and figured out that hey i can make a
lot of money at this right here
and you know what i'm saying i'm a cop
so what what they gonna do
they really don't want to put us in
because cops in jail get done bad
cops in jail get done worse than than a
child molesters and we
don't like child molesters we will kill
a child molester
in the joint even though they protect
them in some states say they're so
protected in some states
it makes you sick you know what i'm
saying you get a hate crime for
for tearing one of their asses up but
let me tell you i tear one of you child
blessing asses up you hear me
you let me know you mess with a kid you
heard me let me know
i bet you i don't give a damn about
prison or nothing else i get at your ass
you know what i'm saying for messing
with kids i will get at your ass for
real
for real and it's like that and the
police even
is with it they'll tell us when one
comes in hey
he's one of those what he don't last
long on the road let me tell you and
what do they do though
oh beat them rape them heavy all kind of
all kind of stuff to they get done how
they do them kids because the kids
those people are monsters you don't
understand but then those people get to
see
some real monsters you know what i'm
saying they get done
they get done worse than they've ever
done a kid you know what i'm saying and
i'm glad to say that
it's so true please know real criminals
do not like them
at all we don't accept them as part of
us of being part of us in the protection
of
you know what i'm saying criminality
criminality
but nowadays the uh the prisons protect
put them in front
nowadays if you slap a child molester or
beat one up you gonna
[ __ ] around and get 10 years as a hate
crime because you
hate a child monster ain't that a [ __ ]
ain't that a [ __ ]
man these people's out there rabbit ass
mine you know what i'm saying and you
know what i'm saying they out they
rabbit ass mind protecting these fools
you know what i'm saying but yeah you
know
it'll be some people like us be right in
there with them and be like
you know what i'm saying it wasn't me
it wasn't me but he better get the [ __ ]
away from me you know what i'm saying
for real you know they still get done
though they still get done
but yeah they're trying to make them
walk the line with us and everything
else but they can't
they catch y'all they get separated real
quick
protective custody is what it's called
protective custody i think they got
different names for it now
i haven't been to prison in a while and
don't want to go back you heard me
don't want to go back you know exactly
who's the most notorious uh gang member
you've ever met
the most enjoyable i've known them all
i've been to starters of them you know
what i'm saying
the most oh man now let me see let me
see let me
oh i raised my skin
monster ken and monster cody
and boy monster cody and my homeboy
devil
i think devil's grooving in peace now i
heard uh i heard he's grooving the piece
i haven't been to the hood in a while
because i'm down here y'all downtown
right now but i haven't been to the hood
but
you know word gets back you know what
i'm saying that
which homies leave us you know what i'm
saying go to a better place because
we all know it's a better place than
this you know what i'm saying and i
ain't scared to get there myself you
know what i'm saying send me
if you can't if you can't sit in me
little man 107 movie clan but yeah
for real though for real though
[Laughter]
cause we hard to fight we ain't hard to
fight
trust we ain't hard to fight
down here anyway whatever mark with him